how was your birthday I'm happy she's
happy to be alive you go to your dinner
you told me everything I didn't my
husband has a cold we came back from the
city and so I actually you know there's
nothing better than canceling dinner I
love making a plan and then canceling
the plan tell me about this feather
moment you were fabulous balance in a
feather moment I work with a beautiful
woman named Jane Ross I was in New York
buying the wedding dress for my
daughter's wedding I was at Saks Fifth
Avenue tolling which is where one goes
and I saw this sweater and I took a
picture of it and I sent it to my friend
Jay and I said do I buy the sweater she
said absolutely and now I'm wearing it
the MA you're fabulous
how are you as mother of the bride it
was beautiful was very emotional with
lovely I mean it's a you've learned so
many dresses you must be the perfect
person to shop when you know what makes
a good gown I actually picked out a
dress all by myself that turned out to
be made by West Gordon who is weirdly
enough married to my daughter's friend
from Camp Paul I mean how weird is that
super powers super powers um you're
being very quiet about that you're being
very quiet about Halloween I haven't
eaten a solid food in two days great a
cow meat eat a burger to me tonight I
know I wish on you bring it to you so
hungry Josie's gonna get me fries after
it's smash burger anyway you're being so
tight-lipped about Halloween can you
tell ét one thing okay take your
feathers out of here then if you're not
gonna tell us anything no I do want to
ask you Taylor Swift are you a swifty
yes is big artist of the decade yes she
is an extraordinary talent but I'm a
Joni Mitchell you have to remember yes
I'm old Carole King is presenting time
okay I mean come on I mean Carole King
Joni Mitchell it was just my birthday
Heidi gave me the Joni Mitchell lyric
book which is so beautiful so no no
old-school
[Music]